let's get reaction tonight from a House
Oversight Committee chairman trey Gowdy
instrumental in getting those Comey
memos released he joins us live this
evening from Greenville South Carolina
mr. chairman thanks for being here yes
sir thank you I want to start by talking
about the release of the memos first of
all you have New York Congressman Jared
Nadler ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee saying this the release of
these memos under the threat of subpoena
by the majority has accomplished little
other than corroborating mr. commis
previous testimony your reaction to that
I read the number six months ago I think
it's important for all members of
Congress and ultimately the public to be
able to see them you can rest assured
Brett if there was anything really
really important in these memos the
Democrats would have leaked what they
read six months ago I do think it's
important that President Trump said if
any of my associates were involved in
this collusion I want to know it I think
it's really important that the Russia
cloud the Democrats keep talking about
was the salacious allegation of sexual
misconduct it was not the interference
and I think we've all learned a little
bit more about Jim Comey as he goes on
his morality tour over the next couple
of weeks do you think he broke the law
by leaking those hambo's have no way of
knowing and unlike Jim Comey I don't
compare people to mob bosses I don't say
they're unfit for office I don't say
they ought to be impeached I I trust
Michael Horowitz I think Michael
Horowitz has done a fantastic job so far
that's the Inspector General let's let
him figure out which memos were given to
the law professor and whether or not
they can contain any classified
information but if they did he would
have broken the law not by the standard
he set in the summer of 2016 I god knows
how hard it would be to win that case
remember he ignored the statute that
says grossly negligent he he now has a
requirement it has to be intentional and
you have to do it to harm the United
States so under the standard he's set in
the summer of 2016 with Secretary
Clinton I don't think Jesus could win
that case now what are those other
things struck you about these memos
there was one part in which he
references CNN I said media like CNN had
them the amount of the dossier he's
talking about here and we're looking for
a new
hook I said it was important that we not
give them the excuse to write that the
FBI had the material and that part was
redacted that we were keeping it very
close hold he said he couldn't believe
that they hadn't gone with it this is
the president speaking I said it was
inflammatory stuff that they would get
killed for reporting straight up from
the source reports I mean it's important
to point out that for five days later
it's leaked to CNN that the president is
briefed on this very thing yeah I
actually think Comey is right that that
CNN was looking for the FBI to have that
material so the story could then be the
FBI is investigating it as opposed as
opposed to the underlying information
but what we've learned through this
investigation is there were lots of
people at DOJ and the FBI that we're
talking to the media
having unauthorized conversations and we
still want to know whether Brennan or
clapper of both of whom knew about this
one of whom was at the meeting if not
both whether or not they could have been
the source for CNN with all of these
interviews has you've been watching them
I've been watching him Comey is going to
be on here with me Thursday what what
strikes you about this and what he's
talking about just the double standard
right you know when he was upset with
President Trump he leaked memos to spur
special counsel when he was upset with
Loretta Lynch nobody knew a word about
it nobody knew that he didn't have
confidence that Loretta Lynch we just
knew that he appropriated a decision
away from himself
when President Trump asked you know go
easy on Mike Flynn he is a good guy all
of a sudden that's an impeachable
offense when Barack Obama prejudges the
outcome of the Hillary Clinton
investigation or the IRS targeting
scandal somehow or another that's okay
so the duplicity the relativism you know
Jim Comey said I don't do sneaky things
except memorialize private conversations
I don't leak except when I do leak and I
don't do weasel things I think this
whole book tour is a pretty weaselly
thing quite frankly you wanted him back
up on Capitol Hill to answer questions
what would you ask them well I want
Horowitz this report to come out first
because I have a lot of confidence in
Horowitz
and I want to know I want to know a lot
of things but I really want to know in
2016
why they handled her co secretary
Clinton's investigation in such an
unprecedented way and if he didn't make
his mind up before July why in the world
were they drafting an exoneration memo
press release in May so there are lots
of questions that I have for him but I
want Horowitz and Muller ticket to
conclude their probes first I think
people are going to have confidence in
the molar and Horowitz probes as opposed
to Congress sometimes but I would like
to ask him more questions under oath do
you have any sense of when those are
going to wrap up either the IG or Muller
I would look for inspector general
Horowitz to conclude sometime in May I
don't know that he hasn't told me and he
would not tell me but but I think the
natural rhythm is sometime in May with
the mccabe part already coming out with
Muller I have no idea I'm not supposed
to know and if anyone does no shame on
the Muller team for leaking it and I
don't think they did finally I want to
get your reaction to this DNC lawsuit
that is moving forward as of today there
are even some Democrats saying that it's
it's not the right move but you've been
looking at this stuff there are a lot of
investigations what do you think of this
move by the DNC it's then it's then as a
wafer I mean the better suit is Bernie
Sanders suing the DNC for conspiring to
give her the nomination that would be a
very interesting lawsuit but there is no
evidence of collusion I know Adam Schiff
wants there to be I know how desperately
he wants there to be but there's just no
evidence of collusion so if they want to
sue Russia that's fine I actually would
prefer the indictments that Muller has
against them as opposed to a civil suit
if they're upset with WikiLeaks so am i
Julian assigns so am i but there's no
evidence of collusion so this is either
a fundraising ploy or it's an effort to
get people in civil court where you can
deposed them so they can learn what
Muller is learning and then they can use
it for political purposes last thing
were you surprised that rod Rosenstein
told the president that he was not a
target of the Kohen part of the
investigation I would be surprised if
anyone
use that phraseology because I don't
know what it means now it was only a
prosecutor for two decades Brett so
maybe I missed something but but that
can change in a nanosecond all it takes
is one more witness to say something so
I'd be shocked if Rosa sine said that I
don't think the president is the target
as you and I use that term in a non
legal sense but in a legal sense that
can change with one witness with one
document so you got to be careful giving
people assurances until the end does he
keep his job I hope he does I mean I've
had my differences with him but but I've
got differences with lots of people I
think they ought to keep their job he's
got a really tough job but I've seen
nothing in his handling of the probe I
mean look people are upset with the with
with the scope and the breadth of the of
the Muller investigation and Rosen I did
draft that memo but look it's a really
hard job to be the Deputy Attorney
General this is a really difficult
environment in which to try to do that
job and the president can get better
advice than for me but I would tell him
to stick with the team he's got now mr.
chairman we appreciate your time yes sir
thank you have a good weekend you too